erricka wrote in saying do you think
people take too many photos of anything
in everything these days I have a few
different ways of answering this number
one I this is we have a picture up of
people taking selfies of themselves at
the Mona Lisa at the Louvre in Paris and
I've been there I've described the
pushing and shoving that took place and
how I didn't get it if you really want
to see the Mona Lisa in detail look it
up online it's more just part of selfie
culture and wanting to be photographed
there which is actually led to the Mona
Lisa having to be placed behind but some
kind of glass that protects it from the
flash which is just stunning I mean it's
unbelievable what's going on I do think
that there is a problem with picture
taking in the sense that by being too
connected to the pictures you're taking
you're often not connected to the
experience you're having and I've been
out at nice restaurants for example and
people are only taking pictures of the
food tweeting about it you know they're
completely consumed in all of the
ancillary stuff that they're not just
sitting there and enjoying the food
right and as we've learned with Daniel
kata from Daniel Kahneman's writing
there's sort of our experiential
pleasure and there is our memory
pleasure and although you're you're
thinking about your memory pleasure
thinking hey if I really take pictures
of this later I'll be able to look back
and remember how much I enjoyed it if
your experiment experiential pleasure is
is not there because you're not paying
attention to what you're doing
how much is your memory really going to
reflect how much you you enjoyed it
because you won't have actually enjoyed
it that much so big picture I do think
that there's a little bit of getting
lost in our technology going on and
taking pictures as part of it yeah I
think there's two different things there
so let's say you and your family go to a
landmark you shouldn't just take a
picture of the landmark because you can
go on Google Images and find hundreds if
not thousands of pictures that are far
better than the ones that you can take
right but I think it's it's just fine as
a nice token of the experience to get a
whole group picture in front of the
landmark or whatever you're visiting now
does the Mona Lisa count in that or are
you saying like so because for me for
example if in Amsterdam there's these
beautiful bridges that go over the
canals in Amsterdam
and when the Sun is setting and there's
these houseboats that are on the river
you can get really really beautiful
pictures of you or whoever you're
traveling with standing there and that
makes sense to me right crowding in
front of the Mona Lisa to get a picture
of me near it where you can barely even
see the Mona Lisa because of the
reflection off the glass that to me
doesn't make sense yeah I think it's
totally fine as long as you don't spend
too much time on it you take one or two
quick selfies in front of the picture or
whatever landmark otherwise it's just
distracting from your overall experience
and now what about really in shoving
what about pushing and shoving to get a
picture in front of the Mona Lisa
well assaulting someone is never okay so
you wouldn't start pushing other people
okay for other reasons I also think that
the I've talked about this before I've
read a lot about the idea of nationalism
and nationalism as in we're the most
powerful we can kill any country that
attacks us and we're just the best that
to me is sort of like a rational
nationalism I think that there would be
a much better nationalism to have which
would be I'm really proud of the really
well-designed cities that we have that
function really really well I'm really
proud of the fact that in our country
scientists and teachers are revered and
respected those are the types of
nationalism that to me actually make
sense in terms of what the types of
things that would make me more proud and
so in connection to that when you travel
somewhere and the pictures you're taking
are more reflective of your experience
of these really great aspects to how a
city or country might be run that
actually is more appealing to me and
when I see people take pictures of you
know whether they're in Paris or
Amsterdam or Rome or Lisbon and and just
the the thought into how these cities
are designed and capturing really really
nice moments and places those pictures
make a lot more sense to me
then I've managed to put a phone in
front of me after shoving ten kids out
of the way at the Mona Lisa yeah and
there's many different things you can
consider here like for example a lot of
people were into photography and that
may have been the whole reason they went
on the trip to begin with right but most
of us are just you know these iPhone
photographers I'm sure there's a term
for it yeah and they want to post things
on social media and me
reflects somewhat in the next year or so
back on their trip right but for most
people it's really not in art form it's
just to brag about the places that
they've gone the other thing about
selfies okay I recently read the book of
life is a website run by a group of
philosophers and it's really really good
and I read a great article talking about
the problem with selfie culture isn't
actually the self-portrait aspect that
for hundreds of years great painters
some of that hundreds of self-portraits
of themselves
the problem with selfie culture is
people trying to capture themselves with
a piece of food or a mug or whatever if
the selfie culture was more oriented at
taking pictures that communicated more
real emotions as opposed to this self
selection of the best moments of your
day selfie culture could be something
really interesting in society I don't
expect that to happen anytime soon
well perhaps to bring this full circle
there's one theory about the Mona Lisa
where that's actually a self-portrait of
Leonardo DiCaprio yeah do you order the
caviar did ability as a woman so I've
heard that's one theory yeah that is
interesting that is interesting all
right those are my thoughts we've got a
great bonus show coming up membership
david pakman.com slash membership coupon
code I voted 17 follow me on instagram
david pakman